but I know choices is a major theme in
the film because it's about four friends
and two went one direction and two went
the other so if you were to relate that
to acting how should an actor starting
out be conscious of their choices I
think that every actors path is
different it's the same way that every
actor who approaches material is
different we're not all the same so our
method some our technique some you know
phone it in every actor approaches
material differently and I think that's
the same for their career one thing that
my agent
I'm a currently who I love he's a
wonderful guy because he understands the
business and he understands actors and
he has said to me that when you start
out in this business you should know
your casting you should know what you're
good at and I think a lot of actors just
come in and they're like you know want
to try out for everything and if you're
more specific about your qualities and
what you can do when you're starting out
then you'll have more success and
eventually you start to you know expand
your horizons and your talents and
challenge yourself in many different
ways and you see it in a lot of actors I
think Charlize Theron who you know
started out as a model then was you know
the leading sexy lady in a lot of the
films and then got notoriety and she
started to expand you know her career
and or take her career in different
directions like monster huge different
direction Halle Berry the same and
that's the key I think we as actors
always want to fight the system want to
fight the casting and they don't know me
or 1/8
but the most important thing is that you
should know yourself and you should know
where your strengths lie in the
beginning and trust that your agents and
the casting directors know what's up a
lot of times you may go into the
audition and you're just not right for
the role you're just not right but if
you give a great performance you'll
leave an impression on the people in the
room that the next time a role comes in
that's exactly right for you they'll
remember and they'll bring you back that
happened to me on Star Trek Voyager I
went in for a role that I wasn't right
for but I did such a great job that she
remembered me and then when they were
casting a younger version of Chakotay
the character in the show they called me
in and I was perfect for it so that's
the thing you should always be aware of
as an actor is that someone's watching
you and you should always do your best
even if you don't like the script the
role you should always be your best
because you want to leave an impression
and you don't want to lower yourself to
the material if it stinks just because
the material stinks doesn't mean you
should and always be your best and even
if you're like oh and I've done that so
many times where you'll read what's on
the page I think for the reading room
where I work opposite James Earl Jones
it said my character was like six feet
one and 230 pounds it said that on the
on the script and I read it now you just
have to sort of push that away and focus
on what you're trying to convey in the
scene what's what's your job
here and that's what I did and I changed
their perception they realized no the
character shouldn't be that it should be
more like to the Spain and I got the job
so always always be your best no matter
what the situation is
you